when I was growing up going to Grandma's
house was always a huge treat and that
we got to go rollerblading in the
basement make a mess and not clean it up
watch old musicals gramps taped on TV
eat freshly fried chips and of course
big bath crisp apple crisp is my
grandma's specialty and judging by how
much we loved it and how often been over
there pretty much just to get it she
acquired quite a few opportunities to
perfect it and I think September was
probably the best month to go visit
grandma cuz it often meant a trip to the
or through as part of the tradition now
apple picking with my family was one of
my first true connections with my food
and was really an adventure in itself I
remember staring up at the sky through
the branches at these arms the size of
my head all the biggest and brightest
apples were at the top where I couldn't
reach so we'd have to get hoisted into
the air and reach with our little arms
to grab them there were a lot of eating
breaks in the course of our day which
really stretched out the whole
experience it's nice you get a really
good wine and you do want to put it in
the bag in case god forbid Oh get lost
and hit up in someone else's lunch so
there's a lot of sampling eventually
with full bags and bellies we all pile
into the car and make a way to Grandma's
house and I remember the pride I felt
standing outside grandma's front door
with an overflowing bag of personally
selected gems I picked these apples for
and I knew the reward was going great
grandma used to let us get as involved
in the kitchen as possible I stand up on
this booster seat and she screw an apple
on to the old rotary peeler and I watch
as the peels would flow down like pretty
little red ribbons I was the only one
that actually liked eating the peels of
course so that was my little sous chef
treat when's peeled and sliced she loves
to toss him in as much cinnamon sugar as
we wanted it on with the crumbly topping
and after what seemed like a lifetime in
the oven it would emerge out golden and
toasty brown my grandma's no longer with
us but the memory of hand selecting
those ingredients and making and eating
that apple crisp with her remains with
me if I close my eyes I can still taste
all those ottimo flavors the apples were
tender and perfumed with the scent of
comfort coded so completely in
caramelized sugar that created this
chewy texture between my teeth the
topping was crumbly and crunchy and
supple and satisfyingly sweet
I used to try to mimic what grandma did
but have since given up the pursuit yes
I know grandma's recipe contain apples
and oats and cinnamon and sugar and
butter and I probably have a good idea
of the amounts but grandma's apple crisp
was also baked with an enormous amount
of a very specific love that I've never
been able to duplicate I might revisit
my mission one day when I have grandkids
in my own but until then I'm simply
happy to relish in my memory of grandma
and are irreplaceable connection through
food so thanks for joining me for
today's gastronomic adventure be sure to
check back regularly for upcoming
episodes of Abby's kitchen where nothing
says lovin like selling from the oven
you